ebola wahlen wäre schon so gut wie unter
kontrolle jetzt scheint der kampf gegen
den virus und alles was damit zu tun hat
von vorne los zu gehen
es ist schon eine weile her dass die
weltgesundheitsorganisation wto liberia
als ebola frei eingestuft hat 42 tage
später gab es wieder in dramatischen
fall ein 17 jähriger starb an den folgen
der infektion
der leblose körper des jungen mannes sei
positiv auf den erreger getestet worden
am 24 juni nicht weit entfernt von der
vom internationalen und iberischen
flughafen in edo wijnen steht verstarb
der jugendliche seit dem traurigen
vorfall ist keine besserung in sicht der
ebola virus scheint kein bisschen unter
kontrolle zu sein und das trotz der
niedrigen ebola basis produktionsrate
von 12 bis 18 zur erklärung wenn sich
die raten zahl der 0 nähert bedeutet das
dass die erkrankungen sozusagen fast
besiegt ist 12 ist nicht allzu weit von
der null entfernt und dennoch ist es so
schwer ebola in den griff zu bekommen
über 27.000 600 menschen sind bereits
mit ebola infiziert worden fast 50
prozent davon sind an dem virus oder
einen folgende starben in den letzten 21
tagen wurde in liberia 69 ifi zierte
gemälde 26 sind verstorben
im mai gab der stellvertretende
gesundheitsminister libere statement
zwar an dass keine weiteren fälle
bekannt sein um das demnach auch keine
auch kein anlass gäbe panik zu
verbreiten damals infizierte sich der
17-jährige junge mann von dem ich eben
erzählt habe verbreitet hat sich zwar
noch nicht die panik aber in der virus
dem centers for disease control and
prevention cdc zufolge sei der virus
nicht von den nachbarländern wie sierra
leone oder guinea nach libyen gekommen
es sei eine leicht abgeänderte freunde
erkrankung aus dem letzten jahr
das heißt in liberia bei ebola
vermutlich nie weg doch wie verbreitet
es sich
eine eher unbekannte übertragungs weise
ist der geschlechtsverkehr nicht der
geschlechtsverkehr an sich und auch
nicht der geschlechtsverkehr während der
akuten erkrankung sondern auch der nach
der erkrankungen und dass das eher
unbekannt die erreger könnten nämlich
noch über 80 tage nach der bekämpften
infektion im sperma des mannes aktiv
werden
folge unausweichliche und extrem hohe
infektionsgefahr
ein weiteres großes problem bei der
bekämpfung von ebola ist unter anderem
auch die beerdigungen der daran
verstorbenen menschen in vielen der
betroffenen ländern herrschen
traditionen dies vorsehen den toten
leichnam bei der beerdigung anzufassen
anfassen müssen auch die hälfe die
infizierten in liberia serie serie leone
und guinea sind bis heute schon über 850
helfer erkrankt die bh und die ärzte
ohne grenzen möchten auch dieser zahl
entgegenwirken
spezielle trainingsprogramme sollen bis
ende 2015 von insgesamt 10.000 ärzten
krankenschwestern krankenpfleger und so
weiter absolviert werden ich bin sicher
dass so viele infektionen unter
medizinischen helfern verhindert werden
konnten so car is equipped von ärzte
ohne grenzen in monrovia so harmlos
ebola anfängt so gefährlich entwickelt
sich die erkrankung besonders tückisch
ist dabei die inkubationszeit die zeit
von der infektion bis hin zu den ersten
symptomen der zeitraum erstreckt sich
teilweise über mehr als 20 tage
es macht uns aber immer noch sorgen dass
wir nicht nachvollziehen können woher
die infektionen kamen erklärte gold die
lange inkubationszeit könnte vielleicht
eine erklärung dafür sein will weiß
schon was er vor zwanzig tagen gemacht
hat
wenn man sich infiziert hat ist das
leider immer noch schwierig die erreger
konkret zu behandeln es gibt nämlich
noch immer kein wirksames medikament in
monrovia hat sich die organisation ärzte
ohne grenzen der medikamentösen
behandlung gewidmet aktuell betreibt
ärzte ohne grenzen unter anderem eine
studie zum medikament karissa gut wir
bekämpfen aber weiterhin hauptsächlich
die symptome der ebola infektion und wir
versuchen zu verhindern dass sich die
patienten mit anderen krankheiten
infizieren
die helfer leisten eine wirklich
beachtliche leistung in den betroffenen
ländern
das sollte viel öfter erwähnt werden in
den vergangenen monaten scheint uns das
thema ebola etwas von der bildfläche
verschwunden zu sein aber mehr zum thema
ebola erfahrt ihr hier oben im video
100% istanbuler impfungen zu einfachen
zum block kommt hier unten und schreibt
uns doch mal in die kommentare ob ihr
euch vorstellen könnte teil der helfer
zu werden würdet ihr euch der gefahr
aussetzen diskutiert das doch mal runter
unter diesem video und bis dann wünsche
ich euch noch eine schöne woche